okay chair and now you're live thank you
morning everybody i'm sorry we're a
couple of minutes late it's my fault i
had some technical glitches this morning
but welcome to this plans committee
meeting
of the 31st of march dealing only with
the one application important
application this morning
which is the brunswick warfare um
i'll just read through a few things that
before we start the meeting proper um
at the start of the meeting we will mute
all microphones or
committee members will mute themselves
actually except mine please leave all
microphones muted
unless you're asked to speak by me
residents who want to exercise the right
to speak at this meeting
have been asked to register in advance
and also have the option of sending in a
statement
to us which will be read out by the
planning officer
or have them they've been sent a link to
temporarily join the meeting to speak in
person
we have um and i've used chairman's
discretion here because we've had a lot
of
requests to speak to the brunswick
application
so we're having three to speak against
the application
and three to speak in favor of it
to indicate to me that you would like to
speak or propose or second emotion
please press the raise hand symbol in
the in the participants menu
on your screen these are shown on my
screen in front of me
in the order that they're pressed and i
will deal with them
in that order giving the appropriate
officer
or counsellor the opportunity to answer
in between where necessary i'll also
return to the counsellor
to check that they're happy with the
response they've received
to ensure clarity and accuracy during
the meet the virtual meetings
all votes will be cast in a verbal
recorded vote
and names will be read out in
alphabetical order
please state your vote clearly and
slowly
and when your name's read out unmuting
and muting your microphone as necessary
please remember that to ensure full
transparency with the democratic process
this meeting is being live streamed on
the council's youtube channel
i ask you all to be patient during this
meeting particularly with me and you
have been
at the start and to understand that the
processes
and advice may take longer than usual
i'll now ask the committee members
to introduce themselves in the award
they represent and also the officers
who are present this evening thank you
sandra steven
thank you chair councillor brown
asker brown you're muted and
good morning everybody i represent the
great torrington ward
councillor christie good morning my name
is peter christie i represent biddeford
north
councillor craigie
good morning everyone i represent
biddeford east
councillor leather good morning
everybody councillor chris leather i
chair the committee and i represent
northern
cancer lock good morning i represent two
rivers three moors which encompasses the
fact the
villages of dalton down and
good morning derby golf and i represent
bit of the north
councillor watson pete watson i
represent broady
councillor wiseman hello there uh i'm
richard wiseman i represent the cheviot
and langtree ward
and kensala hurley morning i'm david
hurley i too represent champion langtry
ward and today i'm substituted for
council about him
thank you jack thank you and now if the
officers present
would like to introduce themselves
please starting with the planning
manager
good morning members and members of
public my name's sean harrington and i'm
the planning manager at torres district
council
good morning i'm stacey dorey i'm head
of legal and governance at toronto
district council
good morning my name's damian hunter i'm
the
legal services manager for the council
and that's it i think there's just uh
those officers present
that's the leather apologies and i was
waiting in my terminals
as chris fuller the economic development
of the secretary of state council
thank you thank you
i'm here as a matthew collins denman
county council highways
thank you matt
i'm just making a note of those for my
right for my benefit but thank you
thanks to that
for everybody introducing themselves
right we can get on there with the
the agenda proper first item on the
agenda is apologies for absence
yes chair i have one apology councillor
bowton
uh councillor holy substituting
thank you sandra and item two on the
agenda is a minute
of the last meeting which was held on
the 4th of march
pages 5 to 12 in your agenda in your
report there i'll move those minutes
from the chair if somebody'd like to
second them
a second that counts as a lot thank you
councillor lock
can we go through the vault please sound
on those minutes of the fourth of
march meeting thank you chair councillor
brown
for councillor christie oh
pencil craigie or penciller leather
or against lock
or councillor mcgough or
cancer watson or councillor wiseman
or hencell hurley abstain
thank you chair that's eight four and
one abstention
thank you sandra
right item three on the agenda is
declarations of interest
i think we probably know this off by
heart there but i'll read it out for
everybody's benefit
members with interest to declare should
refer to the agenda item and describe
the nature of their interest when the
items being considered
elected members of devon county council
and the town and parish councils
who've considered a planning application
by virtue of their membership of that
council
hold a personal interest and are deemed
to have considered the application
separately and the express views of that
council
do not bind the members concerned who
consider this application afresh
so they come to this these applications
at torridge with an open mind
item four on the agenda is to agree
uh between parts one and two there is no
part two
agenda five is urgent matters i've
nothing urgent to report
um i think they've all had the very
latest
uh submissions for this application
they've been email around to everybody
uh five is public petition
participation we have
as i said at the start um
use discretion here to include instead
of the usual two speakers
four and two people's two speakers
against an application
because there was such a lot of people
who
actually wanted to speak in support
and three only three wanted to object i
thought it was fair if we could have the
three objectives
and three of the supporters who'd
written in and there's one two three
four five
six supporters had written in well
they had a the supporters met beforehand
and decided which of those three would
speak so
we've got felicity sylvester objecting
christian nelson objector and that's a
statement to be read out
by the planning manager catherine mar
marlowe
an objective from historic england and
in support
we've got simon friend who's the
applicant
theresa tinsley in support member of the
public
and a statement to be read out from
richard brand
who's the owner of the royal hotel so
those are the
six will speak to this application this
morning
right planning applications
the item seven on the agenda the
information recommendations and advice
contained in the reports
are correct the date of preparation
which is more than ten days in advance
of the committee meeting
due to these time constraints any
changes or necessary updates
to the reports will be provided in
writing or orally
at the committee meeting and as i said a
minute ago we've had
quite a few very late submissions bird
surveys
um shadowing reports so
we have had all the latest um
contributions to this application
so application 7a which is the one
we're to discuss this morning because we
had such a full agenda
and this is a very large application um
we've had to split the meeting so today
we'll just consider the brunswick
warfarm tomorrow the rest of our agenda
will be discussed
um so the first application is on pages
13 to 127 of your agenda
and i'll hand over to sean harrington
our planning manager will present this
application
thank you sean thank you very much chair
uh the application before members today
is application number one slash one one
two six slash twenty twenty
slash f-u-l-m and it's in relation to
the demolition of existing site
buildings and a mixed-use redevelopment
providing restaurant units commercial
units
with public open space car parking
floating pontoon
and associated landscaping works at the
site known as brunswick wharf
article street biddeford next livens
as the chair has mentioned uh there are
a few updates for members
and i'll provide some verbal updates now
um
additional representations have been
received since the publication of the
agenda
and we've had one of support
[Music]
basically stating that it will convert
an eyesore and boost the economy
we've had further representations from
the wooder surgery
reconfirming previous concerns
particularly overlooking
impact and solar pv and location of a
substation
a overshadowing review has also been
received
which has been forwarded to members over
the last week or so
so members would have had sight of that
as well as a
overwintering and migratory bird survey
which included the two final required
bird surveys
again members would have sight of that
natural england have now reviewed
the final bird survey and they've
confirmed that it does not need to alter
its planning advice
so that's as per the committee report
members have also been circulated a
revised plan schedule
and this is essentially to ensure
clarity
on what's been approved if members see
fit to approve the application
in terms of the plan reference numbers
we have also received a harper master
consultation response
the harbor master was consulted although
unfortunately the conversation did go
to a inactive email address so we have
now received that consultation response
and i'll read that to members now
and this is from the uh the bitty food
harbour master
um i've now had a look at the plans and
also consulted with the pilot to ensure
that the pontoon would not limit our
ability to turn ships in the river
which is where we do that particular
maneuver we are comfortable that the
pontoon development and its current
format would not hinder our ability to
work commercial ships
and we are therefore happy to sign off
on this for you all the best uh paul
lapostello harbour master of bidiford
also one final update uh just in
relation to a typo on your committee
report
on page 16. and the eagle eye of you may
have spotted it
but it should refer to four bedroom as
opposed to five bedroom which is in the
committee
report
next slide was
okay so most members will be fully aware
of the site of brunswick dwarf
sean councillor chris just put his hand
up yeah
um i did ask at the harbour board if the
harbour master had
been approached for his views and he
hadn't this is only last week
can i ask when you say that he is now
agreeable
with the pond2 this is the pontoon that
now runs parallel to the key doesn't
stick out into the river is that the
case because all the plans we have show
it's sticking out into the river
uh no the plans have been superseded
some time ago
and the plans which were shown at the
site visit presentation last week
and in this presentation show being
parallel to the key wall
and not projecting out into the uh out
into the estuary
um the redesign was largely due to
the responses from natural england in
terms of
concerns with the sugar sai
and the impact on chiposai and that is
highlighted in the committee report
thank you sean
okay so the location um as i was saying
most members are aware of and we did
have a committee site visit last week
to run through that location it's a
found in a key riverside location at
eastern water bidiford
biddyford is the largest settlement
within the tourist district area
and is a locally significant centre
providing a range of services
retail options education health
and community facilities and also
employment opportunities
and the site is inherited by the red
area
in the center of that slide in front of
you next slide
historically the site contained the
former wolves of brunswick wharf
queens wolf steamer and clarence wharf
the site is located within flood zone 3
and the critical drainage area
and it's partially within the taurin
triple
si the area that's within the triple si
is the area of the pontoon which you can
see dictated by the red
area on the planet in front of you the
site is also within the isla water
conservation area
really a wider area being rich in
heritage assets
which i'll cover later in the
presentation
today the site is found to be a mix of
redundant
wolf land redundant buildings and a 117
space public
car park to the north of the site the
buildings on the site include
vacant carriages warehouse buildings and
office buildings fronting barnstable
street
and brunswick wharf warehouse to list
south of the site
the site is boarded by river torridge to
the east wooder surgery to the north
baseball street uh sorry boston street
to the east towards the west
um and billy ford bridge to the south
next slide please
members will be aware of the site from
the photographs
the site is prominent from multiple
viewpoints
including from the west side of the
torres
and from multiple viewpoints within the
main town centre of bitterford
excellent
filters in front of you now are just
highlighted in sight
when viewed from biddeford bridge
members note the backdrop
of easter water to the rear and the
rising topography above the site
next slide
these slides indicate are taken from the
site and indicate
the uh key wall um and
also the public car park
so barnstable street uh to the east of
this site
um the photographs in front of you show
a view looking north and the view
looking south given the character of
monstable street
next slide
and in front of you we can see the
brunswick wharf building
which is the southern most building on
the site and its relationship
with the royal hotel which i'll discuss
later in the presentation
next slide
again moving on to the existing
buildings on the site
uh these are building the warehouse
building directly fronting
baseball street and members will be
aware of its redundant and dairy
condition and the impact it has on the
street scene
next slide and moving further
to the norfolk possible street former
office building
redbrick building there the existing
buildings on the site were
considered for listing in uh 2018
but were not listed as detailed in your
committee report
for various reasons including lack of
architectural interest
lack of historic interest and erosion
and lack of group value in those
buildings
next slide as stated
there are some more modern garages on
the site
again disuse as you can see from the
photograph
and getting rather overgrown now
next slide so moving on to the
proposal the proposal
seeks consent for 85 dwellings one
restaurant
one cafe five design studios
eight retail units a public square
riverside walk and a floating pontoon
again you can see the pontoon there
running parallel to key wall on the
planet in front of you
the main development will be over five
principal buildings
um those taking the historic names of
the wharf
moving from left to right on that slide
clarence wharf
queen's wharf steamer wharf brunswick
wharf
and a cafe which is sited in the center
of the public square
the site is located within the
development boundary of
um and is in their parcel of land
allocated within policy bid 07
of the north dakota entourage local plan
which states that regeneration and
revitalization
will be supported at the isla water
wharfs which is this site
and it would seek a mix of housing
leisure and retail uses
to improve connectivity with biddeford
west and secure an
active and attractive waterfront use
next slide
so moving on to the proposed site
elevations um in front of you you've got
the east and
west eleven elevations as seen across
the
site members will note the
variety of scales of the buildings
moving from
south to north next slides
in frontal members now are lee clarence
wharf elevations
so this is the building to the far north
of the site
materials proposed in this building
include render
stone cladding zinc standing seam
roofing
and timber effect cladding
the height of the proposal to the ridge
height is 24.5 meters aod
now members should be aware that is an
aod figure
the current key height was if you
go onto the site now the current floor
height is at
5.3 meters aod so that essentially means
that
rich height will be 19.2 meters above
the current ground level
the interconnecting element that you see
there between the
the two principal blocks of clarence
wharf um
is 18 meters aod height which is 12.7
meters
above the existing ground level uh
members will
note although it's quite small that is
proposed that there'll be public
art in the form of terracotta art panels
at the ground level on the baseball
street elevation
next slide
again this is the clarence walk building
uh but leisurely elevations as view from
within the courtyard so this is within
the horseshoe if you like of the
building
um members will note that there is solar
pv included on the roofline of these
buildings
next levels
so moving on to the queen's wharf
building so this is next one down moving
south down the site
it has got a similar palette of
materials which includes
render stone cladding timber effect
cladding
slate tile roofing and also a living
green wall
which can be seen on the elevation at
the bottom left hand corner
in terms of height again it's similar to
the previous building
being 24.5 meters aod which is
19.2 meters above the current ground
level
um with a flat roof element being 20.5
meters aod which is 15.2 meters above
current ground level
next slide
the steemer wharf elevation so this will
be in the location of the existing
warehouse buildings
which members will be aware of which has
the sort of cement
render facing directly onto barnstable
street um
palliative materials here include slate
tiles so more traditional
materials uh render stone clad again
and also with a living green wall on the
southernmost
elevation the height of this building uh
is 20 meters
aod which is approximately 14.7 meters
above the current ground level
uh so now you're looking at the
brunswick wharf building
um essentially this is a rebuild of
the existing building on the site taking
the character from that building
all our members will note it is
different but retains that character
it does retain the plaque to the eastern
elevation
which is of importance to the
conservation area and historical nature
of this site
and that facade but it will be rebuilt
again the materials
are traditional materials being slate
roof
and largely stone-clad elevations
excellent
finally in terms of the main buildings
on the site we have the
cafe which will be located in the centre
of public square
now the cafe is more of a contemporary
design
which you also feel is fitting for the
public square
location of the site
it's got a use of a green roof and
involves
a material stone cladding and metallic
metal cladding
elevations okay next slide
so just so members are aware of these
site sections and the floors within
the buildings the buildings are built
upon flood defenses which i'll cover
later
now i'm not sure members will be able to
see from that's like it hasn't come
across very well virtually
but in the background there are some
dotted lines which indicate
the um existing buildings in baseball
street
um blue royal hotel to the right just
giving you some idea of the scale
moving across to moving north up to the
site
next slide
so here we've got the clarence wharf
elevations
and again these are east to west
sections so it gives you an indication
of scale compared to
the properties on the eastern side of
arsenal street
and if we can zoom in a little bit maybe
able to see
dotted yeah again it hasn't come across
too well but remember to have seen it
from the website
um you can see in dotted lines the
drawings of
the existing sites and existing
buildings to the
east of barnstable street in relation to
the scale of the proposed
building next slide
and this slide is similar but it
indicates the queen's wharf building um
again
in comparison to the um the buildings on
baseball street but just see if we can
zoom in cloud bottom one and
maybe
yep so that's i think you can see it
fairly well the two-story buildings on
barnstable street
um to the left there in the comparison
in scale
okay next slide
so now we'll just run through the floor
plans um
of the site as a whole so
as we can see in front of you this is
the parking element
at the lower ground floor and including
some commercial elements
the parking will be provided by two
undercroft car parks
uh served by two separate accesses
the proposed um parking allocation
includes 45
public car park spaces and that's the
car park to the right
members look at that slide 40 public
cycle spaces
103 private car park spaces
and 140 private cycle spaces the private
car park is the
sort of large cup up to the left
next slide so running through the floor
plans this is the upper ground
level and we will see that the
commercial units here
as well the previous slides are dictated
by the
sandy beige color
the development proposes a housing mix
of one bed properties of 14.1
bed properties are thirty point six
percent three bed properties are forty
percent
and four bed at fifteen point three
percent
um in terms of color coding so members
have an idea of where the
um the units are situated in the site
studio the studio apartments are in
yellow
one bed in blue two bed in green
three bed in a gray
gray blue color and sorry gray and brown
color
and four bed in cyan and pink so we just
move through the floor plans this is the
upper ground
next slide please
site level one you'll see the sort of
the pink
colored elements there that's the design
studios element which could be
potentially live work units
moving up next slide please
will see that as we move up through the
development the height wise
we have the bigger apartments higher up
um
this is normal due to viability reasons
with a developer being able to achieve
higher
values for the properties higher up in
the development so next slide please
so level three uh next slide
level four so this is the top level for
the
next slide please
and this slide just shows you the roof
plans of the development
okay next slide
so a competitive landscape scheme uh has
been submitted for the application
um as members members will see in front
of them um at the moment
uh plants include a mix of native and
ornamental species
excuse me given the poor biodiversity
credentials of the existing site
a 16.56 net gain biodiversity net gain
is achieved throughout the site um
tree planting will be present along
baseball street within the pavement at
barnstable street
and public art and water features
will feature within the public square
element
there will be replacement planting
within the memorial garden
uh which is tilly uh south of the site
far east oh sorry
um to the right of the plan as members
have a look at this site now
the public square is considered to be
well-designed
and an attractive public space which
will attract
footfall we have
looked at potential landscaping to the
riverside
following comments made by members um
however
the ea require um free and unfettered
access
along a width of seven meters across the
entire keyboard
which is why there's no tree planting
indicated on the key wall
as members will see from this
landscaping scheme
next slide
moving on to access arrangements as
members will be aware
we have got the devon county council
highways officer
with us today if there are any
particular questions about this
vehicle access will be via two main
access points
serving the private car park and the
public
car parking commercial elements there'll
also be a shared footway cycleway
proposed along the site frontage uh with
bandsaw street that is
[Music]
from the corner of the site from the
mini roundabout that is
to the existing crossing
to the north of the site and this will
be secured by
a planning condition next slide
more more detailed view of the access
arrangements um
the bus stop and shelter will remain
on the western side of barcelona street
with a new bus stop proposed
on the eastern side and as that plan
shows in front of you
adequate visibility is provided to both
accesses
um to the comfort of devon county
council
thanks a lot
and again a further plan just indicating
the uh
visibility displays um which are
available from those
accesses it should be noted that there
are existing access commercial accesses
at the site um so that should be taken
account regarding vehicle movements etc
next slide
a lighting strategy has been submitted
as part of the application
and it provides to seek to reduce glare
and minimize
light pollution whilst also providing
sufficient illumination fully public
areas
the strategy also avoids illumination
of the adjacent intertidal habitats
which form part of the tortoise chippewa
and also it's designed such that it
won't impact on proposed bat boxes
to impact on the ecology the lighting
includes various different led lighting
including pole mounted
bollard mounted ground mounted
and ground recessed
cctv is also proposed for the entirety
of the development
which will be secured via a condition
members will be aware of the
schedule of conditions as part of the
committee report
this plan also it shows quite well
actually as we're here
the pontoon that's proposed running
parallel along with the key wall
um as opposed to the previously
submitted um
scheme which had the pontoon jutting out
at 90 degrees in the keyboard
next slide
and this is a more detailed view of the
pontoon installation um which i say has
been redesigned
the pontoon will measure 40 meters
in length and a weight for approximately
two meters
it will be a floating pontoon no piling
will be required and no dredging will be
required
which was a concern for natural england
given the triple si
and status of the the estuary
next slide
okay as previously noted in the
presentation the area
is rich in heritage assets and these are
indicated by the red dots in the plan in
front of you
and we see that billy food is fortunate
to have a huge amount of
heritage assets in the main center of
biddy food but also
a cluster in isla water
next slide
as well as the listed structures listed
buildings the site is also located
within the
biddeford east conservation area which
is shown on the right hand
diagram there as members look at this
slide
and as mentioned previously it's also
visible from multiple viewpoints
from the biddeford conservation area to
the west which is
shown in the with the dark line on the
left hand diagram in front of members
there
thanks so a bit more of
a detailed view of the particular
heritage assets that
are impacted by this development
this plan indicates the list of
buildings
in closer vicinity to the proposal
and these are discussed in some
considerable detail within
the members committee report which i'm
sure members
have gone through in detail next slide
so just going through some of these
heritage assets
we have the biddy food bridge which is
grade a grade one listed structure
it's important due to its archaeological
fabric
and pivotal position in the creation of
the town billy ford
it's setting as members will be aware is
vast
and contributes the overall significance
of the structure of this
grade one structure next slide
uh the royal hotel it's also grade one
listed building
um its primary significance is its
internal plaster work
um however the ex the victorian exterior
does provide a landmark building on the
east side of biddy foot
its setting is mixed with positive
elements
to the east south and west but more
negative setting uh
to the north due to the existing
condition of the site
that members are looking at today
moving on to some grade two um listed
buildings that surround the site
here we have uh 26 27 and 28 baseball
street
um which you'll see in front of us uh
the significance is mostly in the group
value
and the setting of these buildings is
contributed through the understanding of
the
historic street pattern of batsmal
street
next slide please
in front apologies for lighting the
photographs but in front of members here
are 17 and 18 barnstable street um
again grade 2 listed so these are
the units so to the right of the
photographs if you like
the significance um are as urban
vernacular buildings
um although there is indication in the
listing of
some interesting internal plaster work
also to these buildings
again the setting is in relation to the
historic street pattern
that they sat within but as per
the previous hedges assets the existing
site does negatively impact
on that setting
next slide
uh just a quick one the uh milestone
which
you can see there um just adjacent to
the existing bus stop
um so the interest there is uh
street furniture and the setting has
been much altered
but the significance is in the actual
stone itself
okay next slide please
uh just what i've drawn members
attention to this photograph so this is
taken from
uh chubby fort which members will know
is tilly east
of the site um and it's potentially the
highest point
um hence its previous uses are fort
on easter water from this view we can
look down into the conservation area
and if we can zoom in we will be able to
see wooder surgery which will give
members an indication
of this site um yeah so you can see the
public car park there
reporter surgery adjacent so there's
glimpse views from chubby fort
freely mature trees
i will discuss the heritage and
conditions uh further at the end of this
presentation
um but members will be aware that is
covered within the committee report
next slide please
so as part of the application process in
negotiation with lee applicant
we have looked at any viable
alternatives the scheme
has put forward members will be aware
from my committee report
that there has been significant
viability concerns
which we raised again later in the
presentation um
a sensitivity analysis has been carried
out um
in respect of reducing the height of the
building or one of the buildings by one
story
again the conclusions of that
unsurprisingly given the wider
viability appraisal what's that that
would be unviable
as a development but also a massing
study has been undertaken
um which tries to distribute the
proposed units across the site so
essentially reducing the height and the
massing of the
proposal by reducing width and let's say
height
and spreading that out over the site
it's clear from the uh the study that's
been submitted
that to do so would be impacting
significantly
on the public benefits of the scheme um
in terms of the public square
and the mixed-use offer
now whilst a fully residential proposal
is likely to result in a reduced scale
and massing of development
this will be contrary to the policy for
this site
which seeks a full regeneration
and seeks economic benefits the wider
benefit area
the just going through the plans in
front of members there
the top there's two sort of diagrams
there the top elements
indicate the existing as proposed with
the bottom elements indicating various
different proposals that we've looked at
to distribute that mass it's considered
that
even with the um the wider distribution
of development there would still be an
impact on heritage's aspects in any case
next slide
um to the north of the site as discussed
is cited wooder surgery
which members are probably aware of um
and concerns have been raised on
numerous issues from water surgery
particularly in relation to solar pv
overlooking and location of a substation
but not restricted to that
representations as members will be aware
covered a override a wide variety of
issues
members will see from the photograph and
in front of you uh
the upper floor windows of water surgery
and also the solar pv on sited on the
roof
the seven facing roof of water surgery
next slide
members have also been included in the
sunpath
study that has been submitted by the
applicant
so the overshadowing assessment has been
undertaken over the spring
autumn equinox summer solstice and
winter solstice
across differing times of the day
um bre guidance with regard to
overshadowing
indicates that the spring equinox
provides
an average level of shadowing
springing equinox at 21st march and
on this assessment demonstrates that
there'll be no shadow
on the roof until approximately 4 p.m
when a small part of the lower roof does
experience some shadowing
with the shadowing growing as you'd
expect
until sunset
and that's a continuation of lisenpack
study um
like i said members have been supplied
that so they are aware um
of that study it is on the website
next slide please
in terms of overlooking an overlooking
study
has been submitted to understand
overlooking implications better
there are a considerable number of
windows and balconies
on the northern elevation of the clown's
wall building which would overlook it
with the surgery
the ground floor windows as you can see
from the overlooking study will be
largely screened
by the existing boundary wall which
members will have noticed from the site
visit
um it is quite high and also existing
outbuildings that were surgery
there will be some degree of overlooking
of the upper floor windows
um with the window to window distances
ranging from 14.1 meters
in relation to uh one of the windows all
the way up to 18.81 meters
so that's window to window distances
the ground floor our current windows are
currently consultancy
rooms at water surgery the
upper floor windows is understood to be
two different uses
however there are no planning
restrictions um stating that they could
would certainly couldn't use those
four consultancy rooms in the future if
they so wished
members will be aware from photographs
that the upper floor windows of water
surgery
can be quite heavily overlooked from
public viewpoints
including from the main highway and the
public car park
as it stands at the moment
next slide
and the photographs uh in front of
members now do indicate
the views into the upper floor windows
uh the view to the solid photograph
to the far right bottom is the
front edge with everyone brown close of
water surgery
i'll just take a drink two seconds
in terms of the flood defense strategy
the applicant has been in discussions
with the environment agency um in the
design of a lift flunt
flood defense strategy for the proposal
which includes uh permanent flood
defenses and
the mountable tidal defenses the
lower car park which is the public car
park
will provide exceeded storage in the
coincidental event
of a peak rainfall event and a one in a
thousand year tidal
lock scenario and that's the public card
what's indicated by this sort of
light blue hatching on that plan in
front of memphis
thanks so before
i go on to the uh discuss the material
considerations for members
um i thought it'd just be useful to show
members some visual appraisal images
um and mock-ups of the um proposal
some of members here uh run down from
the top we've got from barnstable street
looking south um and tristan i'm not
sure we can just zoom in slightly
on that
so we see the materials that have been
utilized to try to reduce the massing as
far as possible
from the design moving down to the next
photograph
this as members will be aware is from
the key side
to the western side of the of biddyford
where you can see the significant scale
of the um
certainly of the clarence wharf in
queenswalk buildings with the scale
reducing
um through the new buildings as we go
through the steamer wharf and the
brunswick wolf building towards
biddeford bridge
and the bottom photograph um shows the
development from the south side
of biddyford bridge but again from the
western bank
where we can see the rural hotel moving
from right to left
the royal hotel the proposed brunswick
wolf building steamer wharf
and then the three main blocks
okay next slide
this is the view from the bottom of the
high street
as members will be aware again looking
directly across
and you can see the proposal with a
backdrop of eastern water
and the existing residential development
at easter water
above the proposed development
next slide please
and just so if you ask this impression
again these aren't members should be
worries on to scale these are just
answers impressions
that gives you an indication um of the
design
and the visual appearance of the
buildings so the clarence wharf and
queenswalk building
at the top left um and the public square
i've run directly on steam wolf clip
bottom right with the
royal hotel behind next slide please
and some street views baseball street
showing indicating tree planting
and that also indicates the the height
of the buildings compared to
the buildings on barnstable street um on
the left hand
photograph top right looking north to
brussels street
you'll see the brunswick wharf building
with the stone plaque
retained and the bottom photograph again
another view
uh looking south along bouncing street
um again
indicating the design of the buildings
and the articulation
of your buildings along baseball street
next slide please
okay so the main planning considerations
as members will be aware from my
committee reports
are in front of you now i'll just run
through um
i trust members have read the committee
reports i won't
spend too much detail on each of these
but we'll just run through them for
members of benefit
in terms of the principle of development
the proposal seeks to provide a
comprehensive regeneration
site in order to deliver wider
regeneration revitalization
a mix of uses and a high quality public
realm
will be delivered which will help ensure
the scheme meets the vision for this
area
a riverside walk which members should be
aware could be continued in the future
pontoon new pedestrian access violent
memorial guarding
and improved pedestrians cycling
responsible street help to improve
connectivity
and provide an active waterfront use
as i've already discussed in particular
scheme will provide 85 residential units
of a mix of sizes eight retail units
five design studios one restaurant and a
cafe
notwithstanding the five year housing
land supply situation which i will
discuss later
as the site benefits from an allocation
for development for a mix of housing
legend retail uses
and is located within the development
boundary of the strategic center
and the proposal does align with the
strategic policies of your north davin
torres local plan
and therefore your officers feel that
the principle of development is
acceptable
moving on to the layout design um the
final design as submitted has been
refined during the pre-app
uh process following discussions with
stakeholders including local foreign
and historic england and i understand
that catherine marlow from stark england
is here today
and we'll be discussing the proposal
um discussions have taken place in
particular with regards to clarence and
queen's wharf buildings
and their scale matching and interaction
with barnstable street
at least in elevations have been
significantly improved to seek to
improve the visual impact on the
buildings which included amendments to
fenestration
um setting elements of the building back
from barnstable street
as far as viable to create a wider
pavement in the cycle way
additional tree planting along particle
street amending roof designs
to reference traditional more
traditional commercial architecture
and a reduced height and reduced number
of window openings
this has led to an improved relationship
with barnstable street
however concern has been raised with the
scale and massing of these buildings
will create a dominant and overwhelming
effect in views
to isla water and within barnstable
street
given the difference in scale between
that proposed and the buildings to the
east side of boston street
notwithstanding this the proposal will
result
in attractive and distinctive public
realm
and the large scale of the buildings are
arctic
are architecturally articulated in a
manner to reduce as far as possible any
negative
impact um given the particularly
constraints and viability constraints of
the site
in general the proposal is considered to
accord with the policies as detailed
within
the members committee reports
moving on to heritage's assets
members will be aware from section 3 of
my committee report that the impact of
the proposal on multiple heritage assets
is a key and extremely important
consideration of this application
historic england have objected to the
proposal as you have noted
although have raised no heritage concern
about several aspects of the proposal
including the cafe uh the approach to
to and details of the publicly
accessible spaces
uh the hard and soft landscaping
proposed um
the reconstruction of the brunswick
wharf building um
on top of the flood defenses and also
the steamer wharf building
as members will have read in my report i
will not repeat its contents
however i will need to remind members of
certain aspects
um section 66 of the planning list
building conservation
areas act states that when considering
whether grant planning permission for
development which affects a listed
building
or its setting the decision maker
must have special regard to the
desirability of preserving the building
or its setting
or any features of special architectural
or star interest which it processes
processes so section 72 of the listed
building act
also imposes a duty when considering
grant planning permission for
development which affects
a conservation area to pay special
attention
to the desirability of preserving or
enhancing the
or appearance of that conservation area
the mppf is also clear regarding the
weight to be given to the heritage
assets conservation
and states at power 193
that when considering the impact of a
proposed development on the significance
of a designated heritage asset
great weight should be given to the
assets conservation
and the more important the asset the
greater the weight should be
this is irrespective of whether any
potential harm amounts of substantial
harm
total loss or lessened substantial harm
to its significance
as it has been determined um from the
committee reports as members will be
aware that the proposal would result in
less than substantial harm to various
heritage assets
para 196 of the mppf comes into play
which requires that bliss harm should be
weight weighted
against the public benefits of the
proposal
i will outline the public benefits
shortly but these are wide-ranging and
significant
the applicant has sought to minimise
harm as far as possible
and the balance has to be made between
harm and benefit
giving great weight to the conservation
of laherji's assets and having due
regard to the special regard to the
desirability
of preserving list of buildings all
their settings and giving special
attention to the desirability of
preserving enhancing
the character and appearance of the
conservation area
in essence for members the effect of the
statutory duties
is that the desirability of preserving
the setting ballistic building
is required to be treated as a factor of
considerable importance on weight
giving rise to a strong presumption
against granting planning permission for
development
which would harm that setting
furthermore general duty
applied to a particular force if harm
would be caused the setting of a grade
one listed building
um which is a designated heritage asset
of the highest significance and
as i previously discussed in members
there are two great one this is
uh of great ones to building rural hotel
and the grade one benefit bridge in
close proximity to this development
uh i'll move on quicker for these next
elements for
members i'll realize time moving on
immediately as previously discussed and
dropped objection has also been received
on behalf of water surgery
located to the north of development i've
already discussed the
impact on the ground floor windows there
would be some
degree of overlook the first floor
windows particularly from ground floor
apartments
um however as previously noted absolute
windows from surgery can currently be
overlooked
to a high degree from the highway and
public car park
the window to window separation
distances is similar to that elsewhere
and as expected in this locality
given the context of the use and the
present level previously
the overlooking is not considered to
result in such level harm
as to want a reason for refusal
moving along basketball street as
indicated within the report
some properties along basketball street
would also be overlooked to a greater or
lesser degree
although given the existing context of
these properties facing directly onto
the road
it is not considered that proposal will
rise give rise to significant
immunity impacts on these dwellings
in terms of immunity would surgery have
also raised concerns in relation to
electrical substations
and generators which will be cited along
the boundary water surgery
a guidance note from western power
distribution
outlines public exposure guidelines as
well as detailing the magnetic
field created by substations
it is further understood from the
applicants that western power
distribution
have been involved in discussions with
the applicant
about the location of the substations
and have raised no concerns with regard
to its proximity to the surgery
given the information to hand is not
considered that proximity and substation
towards surgery
would result in adverse health impacts
while i was discussing wooder surgery um
discuss the impact on the existing solar
pv
which is the next material consideration
um it is considered that there will be
an impact
um on the solar array during certain
times the winter months
and marginally during the spring autumn
equinox
the impact is likely to reduce um some
electricity generation
um although in the context of a full
year's energy generation is likely to be
minimal
given a lack of shading at other times a
year members should be aware that it is
a
material consideration the impact on
renewable energy generation
as opposed to the impact on income
which isn't a necessary plan
consideration um but given
the effect over the entire year um given
the comparative levels of additional
overshadowing throughout the year
um your officers feel that this should
be afforded minimal weight
in the planning balance in terms of
transport and accessibility
uh the proposal makes a number of
changes to the current highway layout
uh to allow regular access to the car
parking under crops
and to facilitate loading for the
commercial units
these car park entrances are sited in
the vicinity
and in lieu of existing site entrances
so it's anticipated
that visibility from existing vehicles
will be no worse than that present
the eastern bus stop on basketball
street is retained with a new bus stop
on the western
side a wide near continuous pavement to
barnstable street
on the west side is proposed which will
also feature tree planting
and a three metre wide cycle footwear
across the site
frontage the cycleway has been provided
following representations made by the
public
and discussions between the applicant
and devon county council
the democratic council highways that is
and provides a potential
link to the trail cycle network um
and this can be secured via planning
condition
development county council have
confirmed that subjective conditions the
proposed development offers safe and
suitable access
at that lead q and that the cumulative
impact of development would not be
severe
as are the tests of the mbpf um
mr collins the devon county council
highway officer is here
uh if members would like to discuss this
element further after my presentation
um i've already discussed car parking
but given the town council's
conversation responsive would be worth
raising again
um the parking allocation proposal in
the submission does include a 45
space public car park which includes
three disabled spaces
and a 100 free space
private car park for the residence of a
proposal
given the application sites highly uh
sustainable location
there are no imprintable concerns about
the on-street or sorry on-site
car parking provision and it's
considered
appropriate to the level residential
units
provided a phasing plan can form a
planning condition
and has been suggested in order to
minimize any impact
to off-street car parking
also if planning permission is
forthcoming your officers would suggest
a planning condition is imposed
requiring the submission of a management
plan
detailing future management security and
maintenance of the car park area
moving on to flood risk and drainage the
tidal defense strategy shows the
position height of the defenses that
mitigate tidal
surface water and tidal lock flooding
the environment agency have confirmed
the new tidal offense when combined with
proposed new defense scheme
will provide a significant betterment to
all existing properties
along baseball street and everwind brown
close
the additional of a surface water
overflow system
will also reduce the impact of surface
water flooding in barcelona street
in terms of surface water drainage um
the ea have noted that the proposed
basketball street
surface water flooding alleviation
overflow
system is welcomed and it will help to
alleviate localized flooding
and compensate for a small loss of
storage the site
currently provides and removed existing
exceedance routes
members will be aware that the public
car park does occasionally flood
all parts of the public cardboard just
occasionally floods um
as existing um the critical drainage
area which is like forgery
requirements um are not applicable given
the direct discharge the river torrid
from the site
um and the ea also welcomed the
consideration of a tidal locking
situation
as i have previously discussed
um further planning conditions will be
required with regard to detailed design
and flood defenses
flood resilient construction techniques
um
however in general the proposal is
considered to accord
uh with um our flooding policies policy
stl free of interest
uh local plan i've just taken other
drink members
almost there it's not too much longer to
go
you're doing very well sean very well
indeed it's a very very
lengthy detail report list and i'm glad
you're taking your time through it sean
okay so ecology the ecology of the site
ecology impact assessment has been
submitted offered by richard green
ecology
this has been supplemented by addendum
report of february 2021
and the latest overwintering birds
report which members have recently
received
the eia baseline data was obtained via
walkover surveys and
bat emergence reports the surveys found
that a building is confirmed to be used
as a day roost
and a hibernation roost by low numbers
of common pistol bats
bats are not considered to be roosting
in any other buildings on the site
um however a license will be required
from natural england
for the demolition of that building a
variety of mitigation measures
are proposed including incorporating
bird and bat roosting provision within
the proposed development
and as previously discussed there will
be proposing proposed creation of
habitats
units with a 16.56
net gain in biodiversity violence
habitat units
providing the measures are secured via
planning conditions
um it's considered that the application
proposal
will have an overall positive impact on
biodiversity interests
at the site and members will be aware
from the conditions in the committee
report
with regard to potential interpretation
in relation to recreational use
of the estuary as well due to the
potential impact on the triple s i
i'll briefly touch on economic
regeneration regeneration of this site
will undoubtedly bring both short-term
and long-term demonstrable and
significant economic benefits
short-term benefits will come through
the investment in the site during
redevelopment
through construction jobs and investment
and services
the commercial floor space will create
jobs in the long term
with high quality public realm
potentially attracting visitors
from further afield um as a destination
particularly given its location in
proximity to the targa trail
um versus potentially visiting the site
from baseball and from uh torrington
the residential units will also further
increase footfall in the wider town
centre
and support local shops and services
the target city council economic
development officer
is here at the meeting today and we'll
be able to discuss this further if
members require
moving on to the public benefits um i've
gone through these at in detail
and given them a waiting in the
committee report so there's no need to
do that but i will just highlight
what they are they include the enabling
the completion of flood defense works
as part of a wider environment agency
scheme
that will benefit from the surrounding
area enabling repair and restoration
works to the wharf
wall and river frontage that will allow
a public riverside walk to be created
increased investment in local area both
during extraction phase and the result
of increased spend by
residents regeneration of the wider
regeneration of the site
provision of 85 new homes on a
brownfield site
within a sustainable town centre
location
creation of a new cycleway along
baseball street uh providing enhanced
connections from the tucker trail to
eastern water and biddeford
heritage benefits through the removal of
a derelict and visually
harmful site within a conservation area
and within the setting of a number of
listed buildings
delivering biodiversity net gain and
other environmental improvements
including the
decontamination of the site which
members will be aware has been used for
considerable time hundreds of years as a
commercial site
provision of a pontoon extending the
offer available
in accessing the river torridge
in terms of viability the applicant has
submitted viability appraisals that
demonstrate
with a policy complaint of level of
contributions the development would be
unviable these appraisals have been made
available
for members of the plans committee to
view on the council's website and the
wider public
bailey benning associates have been
instructed from the council
to independently verify the viability
assessment
that has been submitted and has been
provided by the report
and it is appended to this report um and
i'm sure members who have gone through
the independent assessment
the conclusion of the assessment is that
the application proposal isn't viable
when assuming a policy compliance level
of planning obligations
of the site involves some significant
abnormal costs
including demolition asbestos removal
removal decontamination
works the wharf wall and river frontage
lower ground floor flood requirements
including tanking
piling and a podium slab flood defenses
with swing gates barriers and also
public
realm enhancements following the initial
assessments that was undertaken by
bailly vetting associates and taj
district council are awaiting the
outcome
of an application of grant funding in
relation to what's the wolf war
and this is from the land release fund
which is via
of one public estate as such the vibe
assessment has also been reassessed
on the basis of potential receipt of the
grant funding if torres were to be
successful
although it's noted that such funding
would be conditional
however bva's conclusion in light of any
grant funding being successful remain
the same
in that the viability remains such that
scheme is unable to provide
any planning obligations um and i have
run through in the committee report
planning applications that would be
required including education
contributions affordable housing
etc having regards to the viability
appraisal independent assessment and the
significant abnormal costs associated
with the site
the conclusions of the viability
appraisal are accepted
and the development is considered not to
be able to contribute to any of the
wider planning obligations that would
normally be expected of a development of
this type
mr bailey from bailey vending associates
is in attendance in this meeting if
members have any questions relating to
viability
um so feel free to ask mr bailey um any
questions
so finally moving on to the planning
balance and the conclusions and i will
spend a little bit of time on this
because it is important that members are
aware
of the mechanism for the considerations
of the planning balance
so that there is a robust decision
making process
given the complexities the decision
making framework which underpin
the reports approach the application of
the tilted balance
i wish to remind members of the approach
that should also be followed by members
in determining the application
as the council cannot demonstrate a
five-year supply of liberal housing
sites paragraph 11d
of the mppf is triggered
and i will run through because it's
quite important for members to
understand this i will run through
what paragraph 11d does state and this
states that for decision taking
this means that when there are no
relevant plan policies
or policies which are most important for
determining application are out of date
granting planning permission unless one
the application of policies in this
framework
that protect areas or assets or
particular importance provides a clear
reason for refusing the development
or at two and the adverse
impacts of doing so would significantly
and demonstrably outweigh the benefits
when assessed against the policies in
the framework taken as a whole
now footnote 6 of the mppf lists a
policy that must be
taken into account pursuant to paragraph
11d1
and this list includes policies relating
to designated heritage assets
hence the importance of members
understanding this element
as the proposed development affects the
setting of a number of listed buildings
and the character and appearance of two
conservation areas
policies relating to designated heritage
assets
are engaged under this
limb which is 11d1 the test is whether
the application or policies of the mppf
relating to designated heritage assets
provide a clear reason for refusing the
planning permission
the mere fact that such a policy is
engaged
is insufficient to satisfy lim one um
which would then result in the
disapplication of relativity balance at
them d2
whether or not lim one is met depends
upon the outcome
of applying the policies in the mppf
which relates to designated heritage
assets
to the proposed development to ascertain
whether they would provide a clear
reason for
refusal therefore at this stage
we must stop to consider the heritage
impacts of the proposed development
in that decision-making process the
decision maker
as i've previously stated must have
regard to the statutory duties in
section 66 and 72
of the listed building act um as
previously stated in summary
section 66 requires special regard
to be given to preserving the setting of
list of buildings while section 73
requires special attention to be given
to the desirability of preserving
or enhancing the character or appearance
of the conservation area
anxiety the desirability of preserving
the setting of realistic putting all
accounts and appearance
of a conservation area is required to be
treated as a factor
of considerable importance and weight
giving rise to strong presumption
against granting planning permission for
development which would harm that
setting
this is the case even where the harm is
found to be less than substantial as is
the case
from the officers in this matter
having carefully assessed the levels of
harm the report concludes as a matter
for planning judgment
that level harm to the house assets
would be less than substantial
paragraph 196 of the mppf states that
where a development proposal would lead
to lessened substantial harm
to the significance of designated hedges
assets the harm
should be weighed against the public
benefits of the proposal
including where appropriate securing is
optimal viable use
paragraph 196 requires a decision maker
to weigh the lesser substantial harm
to heritage assets against the public
benefits of the proposal
and members will be aware that i've done
that carefully within the committee
report with
the waiting process
members should be aware that whilst
lessons financial harm has been
identified and are labelled this point
this does not impact on the great weight
and special regard to be given
to the hedges assets conservation as
required within section 766 and section
72
the mppf and policies st 15 and dm07 of
the northern entire local plan
with greater weight being applied the
more important the asset
in essence the effective statutory
duties is that the desirably observing
the setting
of legislative building is required to
be treated be treated as a factor of
considerable importance and weight
giving rise to a strong presumption
against granting planet commission for
development which would harm that
setting
officers have undertaken the power 196
balancing exercise on this basis as per
my committee report
and the assessment is summarized in
paragraph 13.4
to 13.14 of the report and concludes
that the benefits do indeed
outweigh the identified harm
uh if having undertaken the ordering
balance absolutely paragraph 196
members conclude that the benefits
outweigh the harm it can be concluded
that policies of the mppf
that protect designated house assets
would not provide a clear
clear reason for refusing the
development proposal
this would mean that a test in limb one
of paragraph 11d
is not met and the decision taker uh
members of the committee should proceed
to consider paragraph
11d2 of the mppf which is a tilted
balance which members
are are well aware of from previous
applications that have gone to committee
if however members do conclude that
paragraph 196 would provide a clear
reason for refusal
uh the tilted balance is no longer
relevant and members must determine the
application on the standard and weighted
planning balance
having regard to all material
considerations um
as members are aware from previous
experience of decision making
as can be seen from the report
officers have concluded that the tilted
balance supplies in this case uh
notwithstanding this conclusion
the benefits of the proposals are such
that officers would have recommended
the planned mission to be granted for
the proposals
in the event that the tilted balance did
not apply
um and the application failed to be
determined pursuant to
the standard planning balance and the
standard planning policies
finally due to the what i've just
discussed
and the findings of the committee report
the recommendation
is one of approval um subject
to conditions as outlined within your
committee report
and members should be aware there's also
recommended informatives
uh within the committee report um i'm
happy to take
any questions um or any of the offices
that are present
at the committee today from members and
with that
i pass back to you chair thank you very
much
thank you very much sean that was a very
very detailed and long
presentation of the of what is a very
complex and detailed
application um nobody's had their hands
up to ask any particular question
so i'm going to go straight now to the
speakers who are listed
and when i listed the speakers at the
start i failed to mention
uh councillor david brenton who's
requested to speak now he's not a ward
member for easter water he's a ward
member for biddeford south
but under our constitution ward members
of adjoining
adjoining wards can speak at plans
committee
uh meetings when it affects their ward
now
it will affect part of councillor
brenton's ward so
there's only one board member to speak
and that will be councillor brenton
at the end of the public speaking so
i'll go to the public speaking now
um and the first public speaker
uh listed as an objector because with
nobody from biddeford town council
to speak on behalf of the term council
so
felicity sylvester is the first public
speaker
and if you're there felicity you have
three minutes
to give your views to the committee are
you there felicity
chair i do not believe she's in
attendance right
okay well we'll move on then dress up
sorry chair i do have a statement
in uh in the event like vlissy sylvester
wasn't
in attendance um i'm happy to read that
out if if you see fit
if you've got your voice back showing
you all right it's not fine yet
read that out on behalf of it
so it's a statement form felicity
sylvester
my name is felicia sylvester i'm a
trained town planner and
lived number one springfield terrace
behind the rural hotel from 1976 onwards
i knew the biddeford east wharf site
well in those days and have been
interested in their development ever
since
i'm a supporter of way of the wharfs and
have attended and contributed many
events at both projects since
uh 2018. i'm interested in the maritime
history of the site
and visited newfoundland on a
fact-finding trip in 2017.
i am opposed to this plan adaptation in
its current form but i think that there
should be further public consultation in
the summer of 2021
as a zoom in online conversations have
not been adequate and i am aware of up
to 10 local groups who would like to
contribute to this constitute
consultation planning issues
and um felicity has i did some
photographs which obviously members
won't be able to see
um photos to show heights of four blocks
and hollywood effect listed building
conservation area
and the view from buddyfood west
keysight
clarification is required about which
buildings are to be demolished
important that brunswick wolf building
is retained possibly built in 1717.
please see the way of the wolf's
excellent website
buildings on the east boundary near main
road of barnstable street
a problem of vehicle and access site
view as mentioned by benefit town
council
also infringement conservation area
height and light loss
also height of three blocks close
proximity to south side of main road
again dangerous loss of sight onto the
access to the main road
height of block in the north boundary
shown by wooder surgery surveyors report
and
realization of height of block loss of
sunlight and privacy
change for you to oppose this
application
this is why further public conservation
is necessary as most neighbours and
people east of water
maybe also be unaware that these
three-story cable blower blocks
are set on stilts this is for private
parking to be planned underneath and to
combat the possible flooding
at spring tides high wood spring tides
and projected sea water rise in the next
30 years
need to incorporate history of site 400
plus years and further
roman and medieval foundations also need
to acknowledge the fishing history from
the 1600s and once that enabled john
davey to build the new royal hotel
um again see the whale of wars website
in front of their world hotels where all
boats sailed from across the
newfoundland and the grand canadian
banks century also later trading would
end
emigrates to establish prince
edwards island and fishing communities
in newfoundland and tobacco trading
with eastern american plantations type
of dwellings i think it's not acceptable
to have no affordable homes
smaller units for local ownerships and
rental accommodation tdc cannot continue
to justify ignoring the local plan
requirements for
30 affordable inclusion and large
developments
uh beauty for town council by this also
eight shops are not needed
um only fifty percent um so
old thinking pottery and studios are a
good idea
a maritime training apprentice site and
the education center for unique maritime
history could be cited
in empty shop revision or in preserved
brunswick wharf building
an information tour centre maritime
discovery like the braunton
countryside center in the brunswick
building that has been retained would be
far more appropriate and desirable
and will most likely attract funding and
patronage
the architects models are shown in north
daring journal article did not show both
sides of the bridge gardens and the
grade one listed group with the royal
hotel or the conservation area
properties on barnstable street
these need to be considered it would be
good to show and explain in the
constellation exhibition
the flood defense products need to be
outlined in more detail there are often
insurance problems for new homes near
estus and more stringent planning
controls are relevant to
the problem of regular high water tidal
flooding on the site
um devon xl will have more details and
could also set up a display
at a face-to-face public consultation in
the summer
this is an important issue that needs to
need further explanation
dwellings on stilts for private car
parking old thinking but mitigates a
flood problem
where over 100 cars we were relocated at
spring
sea water levels continue to rise this
needs more explanation
conclusions this is definitely a
requirement for further public
consultation in summer 2021
i'm aware of 10 local groups which would
be able to contribute
finally i read in reports on the values
conclusion that's in its present form
the proposed is not viable as shown in
the plan application
therefore there is a requirement to
postpone and rethink
i support benefit town council and
several other statute consultees
such as historic england and water
surgery who are near neighbours
who have opposed the approval of this
planning applications present form
uh felicity sylvester picture
thank you sean can i just say i think
that must have been longer than three
minutes
well i was just about to say council a
lot that
where we're allowing statements to be
made down and starts timing these
statements because
it strikes me people are having a far
longer say
than someone speaking in public yeah
chair i timed that it was over four and
a half minutes
yeah yeah so we're going to put a clamp
on that and i should stop
drawing any statements to a conclusion
right
we'll move on there our next objective
to speak is christie ellison
she she sent you know
a statement to be read again by our
planning manager so
um sean if you'd read that um
yes jeff
okay um so this is a statement from
uh christie elson
thank you for your invitation provided
written submission to be read at the
planning committee meeting on 31st march
2020
we would like you to read out the
following on behalf of wooder surgery we
object to their plans for brunswick
wharf and our representative steve
clements has written to sean harrington
detailing our objections in full
we would like to be clear that in
essence we are in support of project
water development as this would bring
many benefits to the town and our
practice
it would be negligent of us however not
to take seriously any planning
application
which may have a direct impact on our
patients staff and premises
and we request that these concerns are
considered at the planning meeting next
week
our three main objections to their
development are around number one
overshadowing with concerns to loss of
natural light on premises
this will impact on our ability to
generate our own electricity which is a
huge deal for our practice in both the
environmental and
economic sense overshadowing will also
impact on the natural light running
through our windows
into our office and clinical space
throughout the year the overshadowing
reports
show a significant impact during the
winter months where for some of the time
we'll be in complete shade from 12 30
onwards
this is obviously of huge concern to us
not only for the well-being of our staff
and patients
but also for the impact on our pv array
number two overlooking not only our
consultancy rooms but into our offices
we understand that there will be at
least 36 windows some with balconies
directly next to
our premises agree that not all of these
windows will look directly into our
consulting rooms
however overlooking is inevitable based
on the plans provided
and our staff and patients have a right
to privacy when attending our premises
now and in future which is something
that we are not willing to compromise on
number three concerns around exposure to
electromagnetic fields
are concerns around risk to health for
our staff and patients
and also useful medical equipment have
not been delayed
the company directive produced by
western power is a document staff
working for western power
and does not address our concerns only
recommends that an occupational risk
assessment is carried out for planning
for people working within close
proximity to the substation
our concern for the health of our staff
and patients in relation to the location
of the substation
are genuine and we have received no
assurances that staff and patients will
not be put at risk
i hope that this goes some way to
explain opposition of course we
understand that opposing these plans may
be unpopular
and we take the reputation of our
business very seriously indeed but first
and foremost is the health safety and
well-being of our staff and patients
kind regard christie elston practice
manager
thank you sean that that statement is
what
what we've all got i think all members
have got that it was it was emailed
round to us all so
that's a repeat of what we've already
had okay our final
speaker object into the application is
catherine marlow from historic england
and i see you are here catherine so you
have three minutes thanks to uh
give your views to the committee thank
you thank you chair and members of the
planning committee
i'm here to represent historic england
the government's adviser on all aspects
of the historic environment
we're a statutory consultant for
development such as this one
in this instance there are two grade one
listed structures in close proximity to
the site
biddeford bridge and the royal hotel as
well as numerous grade two listed
buildings and two conservation areas
grade one list of buildings make up only
two percent of all listed buildings in
england
and are of exceptional historic interest
their interest often stems not just from
their historic
fabric and age but from their context
and settings
members will note from the planning
officer's report that historic england
have objected to this application
it is rare for historic england to make
an outright objection
we do this only in situations where we
have grave concerns that irreversible
damage will be caused to the historic
environment
in this instance we have no concerns
about several elements the development
proposed
we can see the landscape social and
regenerative benefits of some parts of
this proposal
however our objection stems from the
scale of the accommodation blocks
proposed in the central
and northern parts of the site these
blocks are five stories tall and sit on
top of a raised flood
fence the finished height will in some
areas be more than twice the height of
some of the existing houses on
barnstable street
the scale of the blocks is significant
the impact of the proposed buildings on
several views to east the water from
biddeford
and from the grade one listed bridge and
within east water will be dominated by
development of this scale we appreciate
that with the development will come
housing
possible regenerative benefits a section
of flood defenses and publicly
accessible space
however we believe that similar benefits
could be delivered through alternative
schemes
which would be less harmful to the
historic environment
we are not convinced that alternative
layouts and options for the site have
been properly explored
accepting development of this scale on
this site may set a tone for other parts
of biddeford
it will demonstrate what the council
considers acceptable and what levels of
harm to the historic environment it is
willing to accept
biddeford is a beautiful historic
riverside town it attracts people to
visit because of its character
its buildings are too
appropriately developed in the past
unlike many other towns of similar size
and with waterfront locations
we do appreciate that developments can
provide associated public benefits
but we strongly feel that the proposals
must fit into the character of the
existing area
and not impose upon that character
development should reflect the scale of
the area and complement it
and not dominate it we hope that great
weight is given to the conservation of
historic of the historic environment in
your decision making
and thank you very much for listening to
me
thank you
you need to unmute chair
thanks councillor watson yeah thank you
uh catherine for that presentation
um but i think you'll realize from the
planning
uh presentation his the historic aspects
of
this site have been fully considered and
taken into account and
has his historic english contribution
right
we'll move on now to the those to speak
in support
and we've got simon friend who's uh the
applicant for the site
and if simon's there he's got three
minutes just i see councillor mckenzie
got your hand up
i'll bring you in after these speakers
simon friend uh is the applicant and you
have
three minutes simon friend to speak to
the committee
chair thank you good morning councillors
my name is simon friend and i am the
owner of red earth the applicant
we've directly engaged with wooder
surgery and provided a range of
technical information to address their
concerns with your planning officer
which he has gone through and i believe
we have fully addressed
their concerns there are many challenges
with this site
flood issues site contamination a
failing harbour wall
these and other challenges proved too
much for the previously granted scheme
leaving the site vacant my vision
is to invest over 20 million pounds to
transform a currently bleak
and underutilized area into a vibrant
new heart for the community but more
than that
i want to ensure that these proposals
will be delivered
i have the support of many stakeholders
in the planning process
but i've had to draw the line at changes
that i know will threaten
the ability to build this out i
do not want this to be another failed
attempt at regeneration
in 1894 the hugely ambitious wca
mill building was celebrated as a feat
of modern engineering
you may not be aware that it stood at
least
two meters higher than any of our
proposed buildings
i too want to celebrate great design
which respects the beautiful
architecture of this town
and historic significance of the site
we've worked hard with historic england
over many months and there are many
areas of agreement in the end though
there is a planning balance to be made
and i welcome your officer's conclusion
that that balance falls in favor of the
development
and that the scheme with its public
square and riverside walk
will bring a renewed vitality to east
the water
i also want to celebrate that biddeford
sits at the heart of the north devon
biosphere
by building highly energy efficient
homes
that use renewable energy sources
i want to celebrate that we are cited
close to the triple s
i and with our imaginative landscaping
proposals
will achieve significant net gains in
biodiversity
with the reuse of this brownfield site
surely this is exactly the sort of green
sustainable development that we should
be building
in times of challenging climate change
i also want to celebrate the history of
creativity on the site by commissioning
with the help of the burton at biddeford
public works of art
most of all i want this to be a place
that biddeford will be proud of
where people will come to relax and
enjoy fresh perspectives of the town
i'm delighted that there has been so
much public support
and i hope you will wholeheartedly
affirm and support this application
before you now
thank you for listening thank you mr
friend thank you for that
i would our second speaker in supporters
teresa tinsley
teresa if you're there please you've got
three minutes
to present your case to the committee
thank you
yes hello everyone i'm speaking as a
resident of east the water
and somebody with a long-standing
connection with biddeford
many years ago i used to pass brunswick
wharf on my way to school
and it was a mess but then it was an
economically productive mess
now it's just a disgrace i saw
is the word used by so many of the
masses of people who've commented in
favor of this application
has there ever been a proposal which has
received so many
supportive comments from local people
coming back after i've been away
my heart would lift the first side of
biddeford as you come over the hill
the bridge the river the little white
town
but by the time you reach the bottom of
the hill by the royal hotel
all you see is dereliction and
abandonment what a way to welcome people
to the town
how could such a wonderful site not be
better cared for
what's wrong with the east side of the
water that it gets no attention
so now i'm very pleased that it is
getting attention
there's a vision there that recognizes
biddeford's assets and what it could be
i understand that it's a difficult site
brownfield sites always are
which is why developers prefer to build
on green fields there's a flood risk
too and the aspiration to build a public
space that everyone can enjoy
this all adds to the cost so i
understand why not everything is
possible
of course we want social affordable
housing
but there's already plenty of that in
east the water
and the ethel wind brown site is just
next door with its own riverside walk
of course we want green spaces but let's
look after the ones we've got rather
than trying to recreate
nature in a prime spot that's been
developed for hundreds of years
and i've been very impressed by the way
the developers been so
sensitive about respecting the character
and heritage
connected with the site and protecting
uh wildlife in the marine environment
there are things we have to compromise
on the height of the building for one
and yes there might be more traffic
which is why we need
better cycling links i commented
originally as a member of the northern
devon cycling campaign
and we're in conversation with officials
and councillors
at torridge and devon county council
about doing more to improve facilities
for cyclists and walkers in this area
in the area around the site and
particularly access to the taka trail
so yes there are things that in an ideal
world we'd have wanted doing differently
however the question now is not what we
would ideally like to do with the site
it's too late for that it's a choice
between this plan
and continuing dereliction this plan has
been 30 years coming
and i don't see an alternative appearing
in my lifetime
this is the last chance we get to say
yes
to an investment of funding which will
transform our area for the better
generate income for the town and make
many more businesses viable
my message to councillors please do not
throw away
this opportunity thank you
teresa tinsley for that and our final
public contribution
is a statement to be read out by the
planning manager
it has been overworked this morning with
these i think uh from richard brand
the proprietor of the royal hotel
thank you sure a statement from richard
brand
i would like this statement to be read
out in support of the above application
being considered by the plans committee
on the 31st march 2021
we as a friend group have owned and
operated the royal hotel
since 1969. as you might imagine trying
to run a hotel which looks out onto a
derelict site
which has been in steady and worsen
decline for some 15 years is not an easy
business
what is left of the wharf site building
to present stark and bleak facades
facing directly opposite the hotel it
has become increasingly difficult to
attract guests and tourists to the hotel
when fundamentally there is such a poor
outlook sustaining business for a hotel
like the royal hotel
is becoming increasingly difficult and
especially so during the current
pandemic crisis
we are firmly of the view that the
proposed development will make a very
considerable difference to the business
of the hotel
and therefore be a significant factor in
ensuring we can continue to run a
sustainable operation
we believe these proposals will be a
great addition to easter water area
and attract more visitors to the area
we are mindful of the grade one status
of our own building
and we believe that this scheme will
enhance the setting of our own building
and provide the economic regeneration
and boost to local businesses
like ours which will result in our
ability to continue to invest in the
preservation of the royal hotel
building and fabric for safeguarding
this important heritage asset
we are surprised by historic england
stands as the only reasonable conclusion
for those of us
for those of us trying to maintain an
important list of building
is that more harm is likely to result
from refusing this application and
granting it
a refusal would blight this site for
many years to come
and therefore make our business even
more difficult to sustain
a healthy business is needed to ensure
that the important fabric of listed
hotel
is maintained for future generations to
enjoy
certainly our message therefore to the
plans committee
is that we very much welcome these
proposals and hope that this development
will be granted permission
and come to fruition it will be a major
and much needed regeneration project for
the whole town
yours and city rich brand director brent
hotels
thank you sean before i bring in
uh councillor um
brenton councillor mcgoff you've got
your hand up
sorry mr chairman i'm just trying to get
myself ahead to speak after the public
speakers and the other councils
all right all right thank you yeah all
right well we aren't finished with the
speakers yet
councillor mckenzie you're a ward member
for easter water i see
you're not a member of this committee
but you are the war awards member for
east walter
you put your hands up here yes i did put
my hands up chair
can you hear me i can hear you what
point
that's okay i was going to bring up a
point of order if i may um
councillor brenton's going to be allowed
to speak but he is a member of the south
ward
um and which is not adjoining the
development site that would be the north
ward so would that
prevent him from speaking um as per the
rules of the
planning committee no he does a joint
bid of itself does he join the east ward
it does join the east but it's his which
is
yeah um i did explain at the start that
counselor brenton had applied to speak
and because he's
his ward adjoins this ward that's got
the application
sighting um that's the reason i'm
letting councillor brenton speak on this
is it it does okay it does affect
the south ward the views from over there
the diffuser to the northward not the
southward well anyway
the the opposite bank of the torridge is
um in the northward not the subway
so it wouldn't affect the southward at
all as a view part of the south ward
is on the river torridge part of the
safe walk comes down onto the river tori
yeah but not that part so um anyway i've
allowed council of black to speak
he'll be our final thank you he'll be
our final speaking i saw
councillor brenton if you'd like to
present your
case to the committee uh thank you chair
yes i i am perfectly entitled to speak
as you well know however
um first thing i want to establish is
the fact that i am not
against development over on the
the the wharf sisa east of water i was
born in insto
and i've lived in beverly all my life in
north devon all my life i'm very
passionate about
our community uh secondly i would say
that
this proposed development affects the
whole a bit of not only the whole of
biddeford but torridge
as well because tourism is going to be
our main industry
if it's not already and we have in
biddeford
a really delightful town with plenty of
conservation areas and listed building
grade one listed buildings and we should
not detract from that
no members will know that i sent you
some photographs of some balloons
uh floating up unfortunately the wind
took them of a little bit
and they all leaned over at about 45
degrees
so those heights actually were about a
third less than what they should be
and i always prime myself with the fact
that i've got a pretty good idea of what
three dimensions
are but i was horrified actually
how high these proposed new buildings
will be
listen to the presentation made by
historic england these buildings are
going to
obliterate the conservation area of
eastern water if you're on the town side
of biddeford
no question of that it will not enhance
it in fact those photographs
that sean harrington put up earlier are
showing the view from the bottom of high
street across
they should give you some indication
where you've got virtually
three bridge buildings side by side
that's how big it is
now back in 2016
here's the picture here i don't even see
it that was a gazette
saying that 52 dwellings were too much
by both uh jenny wallace and general
whitaker at the time
it was too much at that number so at 85
goodness i mean what is going on here it
is definitely going to be a blot on the
landscape
we must re-look at this and the doom
gloom that says if you turn this down
then you will uh throw away all
opportunities
not at all not at all it could well be
the catalyst
to make the town council and a district
council get our act together
and make sure that that area can be an
asset to the
whole of the community not just for the
men of
a developer so really i would appeal to
your committee members i know it's going
to be very courageous
very courageous to turn this down you've
heard some very strong arguments
in favorable but it sometimes
courage is required in these instances
and i think really
that also the developer has
indicated things that were misleading in
a way that the pontoon
for example i was told that was an
aspiration originally
it's not at all viable i've had a boat
in a river i mean that
that area is a mud flat neat tides how
is that going to work who's going to be
reliable
for the um the public liability of that
and the upkeep
it's just it looks good but it isn't
feasible at all we had all that but more
than before
we made mistakes let's not repeat them
thank you chair
thanks councillor brenton right that's
the
that's the end of the speakers now
before i go to the first speaker which
will be
uh committee members should be
councilman i just
briefly sketched of an introduction i
think i'm going to repeat probably some
of the things that sean harrington said
in his
presentation but i don't normally speak
at the start of an application i let the
members speak first
and i tip in later on normally but i
just want to set
the scene as i see it this is an
extremely
important application with far reaching
implications
for the future of biddeford it's been
designed based on the development brief
of torrey's district council for this
derelict site
for too many years this site is sat like
an open wound
in the heart of biddeford and in the
easter water conservation area
festering and decaying and blighting the
river frontage
members will see from this very
comprehensive report from our planning
manager
no question has remained unconsidered
all relevant local plan
and mppf policies have been studiously
studied
consulted and reported on there are 12
12 pages of public comments the
overwhelming majority
support the proposal from page 58
through to page 88 of the report it
highlights the planning considerations
with all our applicable development
headings and policies considered
including all the heritage aspects
public benefits are described at the
bottom of page 83 onwards
and the possible weight to be attached
to them within the planning balance
page 86 addresses the viability in
section 106
obligations members will have noted that
tdc engaged
barely benning associates to
independently verify the
viability assessment and you'll have
heard the planning manager mention that
mr bailey's here
if anybody wants to question him on that
pages 88-91
refers to the planning balance and
conclusion
with a recommendation to grant with 31
conditions
attached it's now for this committee to
work through all the planning
considerations
and relevant policies material
consideration
and planning balance and i'll go
straight to counselling the gulf
thank you mr chairman um i do echo your
uh something emotional views there
well let's say mr chairman obviously
this is so important
for eastern water and biddeford this
deserves economic regeneration which is
paramount within positive growth within
the town
which should increase the investment for
the local area providing public immunity
space
and improved entrance on the basketball
street this is an important thing for me
the improvement entrance on barcelona
street because
as a local walking past of time when you
see children at school time coming along
that pavement is so dangerous so i'd
like to thank the highways officer
and the developer and torres working
together to me
it it opens the street up and provides a
lot of safer space for everybody
now this this development is you know
this is a catalyst really going forward
for the
increased improvement and benefit bit of
it needs this
for the uplift of the town or we're
going to stay in the doldrums
forever it doesn't deserve this so i am
proposing that we accept the
recommendations set out on page
91 from the offices i think the report
has been an absolutely
fantastic report very detailed report
you've had letters of objections you've
had a lot of letters of support
now when would it touch you under wooder
i'm pretty sure the developing officers
will work closely with them
to try and alleviate some of their
concerns but
no one's breaking any rules bending the
rules here it's a
positive development for easter water in
general
now i'd like to touch on the tourism if
i may please mr chairman
um we've just been supported by one of
the main tourism
business owners a mr brend of the grade
one listed
royal hotel who's actually in support
and he actually
says this would improve his business
which i totally agree with to be honest
because when you look at a nice hotel
and looking to derelict
it's just it is an eyesore i think one
lady alluded to earlier on um it is an
isil
and it needs to be improved and to me
it's the catalyst with public you know
for
the change of biddeford and the provide
with the loss of car parking spaces for
members of eastern water there
well we still got provision for public
spaces over there we still got
provisions for disabled spaces and we've
got provision for
a cycle spaces there as well and also
the public immunity space within the
development itself
provides the public with a lovely walk
through to that river frontage you've
never been able to do that before
it's been a car park in that war for
many many years decades
now we actually the development's been
lifted up opened up now
now i touched on kaz brenton's thing
about the pontoon
it's staying in the personal reception
is it you just whether you like it you
don't like it i think
but to be honest the viability of it
that's not really down to me
if developers can put money into it the
cost of ongoing cost of it i hope
there's a clause in by the council
which doesn't come out of taxpayers
money we can put clause into that but
with the improvement of that wharf that
side with the
actually see war defense itself we're
actually liable for the accountability
defenses around here so with the
improvement from the developer to
actually
uplift it for us a beginning then for us
to maintain it in the end to me it makes
economic
sense mr chairman thank you much for
letting me speak
thank you councillor mcgoff councillor
locke
yeah well if that is a proposal from
captain uh
it was a proposal to quote i will second
that um
recommendation but i would also like to
make a general statement as well
before i come on later on to discuss one
or two concerns
i mean this prop this project will bring
new life into this completely derelict
and unkept site
it will be a catalyst for future and
further regeneration schemes which is
exactly what benefit needs
for anyone driving into billy button
sees its site it just gives a massive
negative perception of what the town has
to offer
and benefit deserves so much more i
actually worked in biddeford
40 years ago and and i've seen what has
happened to the site
since and been on the council for the
last
x number of years i could have been in
benefit for
four or five days a week and i have seen
how badly the site has degenerated
i mean the town is crying out for new
investment and other local businesses
have shown their support for this
application radix
won and we have heard from the owner of
the royal hotel
if i was a visitor stand at the raw
hotel no matter how
excellent that hotel facilities were i
would always remember one thing
the views on the opposite side of the
road i also think of all the visitors
arriving by a coach
independent and being dropped off at the
key looking across to east the water
as it is at the moment does not
encourage them to walk across the bridge
and visit the site
i mean there are over 80 letters of
support on the plan in portal and i have
opened every single one of them
and read them but none of them actually
show addresses
there's two objections with a surgery
and three other objections
and i was concerned about the winter
surgery representations but i'm sure
that would be discussed later on
so i will i'm fully support on this
application but we'll come back with
london to
concerns later on thank you jam
thankfully
thank you council a lot councillor
craigie
thank you chair um i just wanted to ask
if we could have more
details of um the archaeological
investigations that will go on because
i feel it's really important to preserve
the history of the site
and we haven't really heard a lot about
what's going to be done i'd like to hear
more details and then
i'd like to be sure that there's going
to be a positive plan
put into force you know before building
starts
thank you thank you sean would you like
to answer council craig you're there on
the archaeology
conditions to do with the site yeah of
course chair
um the devin county archaeologist has
been consulted and
is fully aware of the site and has been
working with a developer on it
uh committee members will see from their
committee reports and i'll just
favoritely i'll find the page numbers i
can at the moment
that we have had two responses from the
archaeologists
on this uh if you're just going for a
second
yeah so i was just looking for the
archaeologist's response sorry page 39
report here we go
so starting from page 59 we've had the
first uh response from the
archaeology section
and then a second response on page 40.
so the county archaeologist um has
looking at the written scheme of
investigation
that has been submitted and they are
content with that um
there is a condition on the uh on the
proposal as you will notice
they believe that it's in accordance
with the planning policy of dm 07
and that an appropriate record will be
made of any archaeological
evidence that may be affected by the
development
so we're as obviously comfortable that
the county archaeologist has looked at
the scheme
has worked with the developer and the
written scheme of investigation
is robust thank you sean
councillor watson ah thank you chair
well well done sean
you you relay your money today uh i'm
very proud of you and and the report you
put forward
it's a really great report
and i can't really say any more chair
because
councillor lock and councillor mcguff i
echo
everything that they have just put
forward and and they're absolutely right
it's it's a disgrace that places on it
on east the water
and as as council lock said when you
drive in from there
you think where have i come to
and and you know it might well be
historical
historical historical england say well
they need to
um have something that is um um
fit basically fits in better but then
the guy from the from from from from the
hotel
says that he's for it because it will do
his
hotel uh with a lot more business
and he needs to make make business
a big good business so he can keep up
with with
looking after um the grade one listed
building
now without that or
historical england going to provide the
money for him to do it
no i don't believe they will but they'd
like to tell him how to do it
so i echo councillor council lock and
councilman
mcguff's um what they put forward and if
either of them didn't have
proposed it or second it i would thanks
jeff i'd just like to remind members
before being councillor christian that
historic england
have made their representations known
and you've heard
um catholic marlowe speak this morning
on that so
i'd like to hear some views on the
effect that this proposed development
will have
on the heritage assets the listed
buildings and the conservation of the
area release of water
i'll bring council of christian now
thanks council president
thank you mr chairman um well i've been
a bit of a counsellor now for
uh 38 years um i'm currently serving my
fourth term as mayor of biddeford um
i have been a member of the british
trust the british trust used to own the
bridge
we looked after it for hundreds of years
i've been a member of that for 36 years
and i've been chairman of that three
times
i've written 40 books on the local
history of north devon
half of them have been on biddeford now
i mention all this because
to me um the crux of this application
is the impact on the bridge uh this is
why historic england is objective
uh before i go on i should say it's
clear that everybody
wants something to be done with this
site we've all
we all know that something has to be
done with it but we only get one chance
because what we decide this morning will
actually
decide what goes on that site for the
next hundred years
so you are actually voting for the
future today
now i'm going to suggest something we do
here because um
we have to be very careful
when the first application came to build
the first tower block in westwood ho
i voted against that and look what's
happened in westwood home
we've seen tower block after tower block
you may like them personally i don't
we've got to be very careful what we
vote for this morning and i wonder if we
shouldn't go for a design review
now a design review for those of you who
haven't come across it before is where
an independent
third-party group of experts critique
the proposal to provide a more robust
outcome i understand this has been done
in north devon already for baseball
civic center the future of that also
yellen key
where people have come in from outside
just to look at this if it does come in
if we do it go that way i wonder if we
shouldn't include the counsellors
because all i've heard this morning is
talks between the developers and the
planners
the councillors don't seem to have
involved and the public certainly
haven't
there may be letters of support unless
there's objection on our website
but i think this council a lot pointed
out there are no addresses
on any of those and i've raised this
before i get very worried about
um anonymous all you get is a name and i
don't know where they come from
and i'd like to know but anyway um if we
did go for a design review we could
include the public
and we could actually come up with a
scheme that suits everybody
i don't have any problem with the scheme
if
everybody uh was accepting and of course
that isn't so and personally i have a
problem with his impact on the bridge
thank you mr chairman thank you
councillor christine
um councillor hurley thank you chair um
i think uh councillor mcguff and council
lot made some excellent points
i think cancer christie's recent point
there about the bridge
i think the biggest impact is on the
bridge having looked at various photos
and walked across that bridge many times
realized where the impact is going to be
but
a couple of points the town council
weren't happy
about the entrance or the exit onto
basketball street but the car park
president car park doesn't seem to have
too many problems with vehicles coming
on
and off there as far as properties goes
i can understand
historic england being upset or
concerned about the impact on properties
but when you look at barnstable street
26 27
8 what are they doing they're looking at
a concrete wall at the moment
at least they can't see over that
concrete wall
but a higher property it will look
better that the new proposal will look
better than the concrete wall
17 and 18 barnstable street look at
redundant garage block
and also a concrete slab so again
their outlook will still look better
even though they can't see from benefit
from where they are once that what goes
up
this these plans have all the support
for this
venture has been ongoing for many many
years many many uh committees
at um torridge have supported
uh regeneration of this project and i
think it will
assist in the regeneration of biddeford
the site itself is a mess
if it stays like this nobody will come
forward for years and years and years
because
costs will go up we've seen the
viability of this
we've seen the viability reports we've
seen exercises of trying to
change the layout but whichever happens
whether layout is there someone will
always be opposed
to it but there has been far more uh
consultation support than objections and
interesting that mr bren
has supported it because this proposal
will affect his business more than more
than anything down there to be fair
i'll finish by saying the last thing i
looked at was one
um letter of support and this is
so true it says it's clear that this is
not a straightforward
site and there was always going to be a
need for compromise and concessions on
all sides be able to achieve an
attractive
and useful development while ensuring
commercial viability
a long-term sustainability to me that
sums it up completely
whatever is proposed there will always
be someone who opposes it
and i believe the developers in many
ways bent over backwards to try and help
all the various complaints or objections
to the policy
and i think i for one will support this
and i think we should support it as a
committee
thank you chair thanks councillor
herrera councillor wiseman
thank you chair i didn't realize i was
next um yeah i mean i'll bring cancer
unlocking after you because
obviously there's been many good things
said um we've just we've received nearly
two hours of submissions this morning
i've spent hours looking over these
reports and the information on the
website
so forth i even went and reminded myself
of what the
what the site's like uh last week when
we were allowed to travel around again
um i spent a couple of hours walking
around it again it's obviously going to
be a big change
for biddeford um and ever
and everybody seems to have an opinion
about what they would like to do
differently
but we have to deal with the submission
that's in front of us like we always
have to
and that whilst it might not be perfect
and i've got some
i've got some issues that i'm not 100
happy with
the effect on the solar panels and so
forth is one of them
but on on balance looking at the public
good
that this is going to do we've heard
we've already people have already
mentioned that so i don't need to go
through it all again
i feel that i've got really unless
anybody comes up with a
with some sort of brainwave that we
haven't had yet i've have i've no choice
but to support this
uh application thank you clemson wiseman
councillor locke
yeah just coming back on captain
christie's um idea of putting out the
design
review for members of the public i don't
think that is the way to go forward
because that will throw even more
spanner in the works because every
single member
of the public will want something
completely different so i think that
would be open further kind of works
and with regard to council brenton's
comment about
it would be a matter of courage to turn
this down
i think plans committee members are well
aware that you don't make
decisions on courage or popularity you
just make them on
you know planning considerations um i
don't know if anyone
talked about affordable housing um i
don't know if anyone has watched the bbc
two series on a sunday night about
cornish fishing
and one week they particularly um
focused on
how and what they've done to the north
key down at hale
and they negotiated with the fishermen
to improve their
existing facilities and they are
delivering luxury
peace side apartments retail unit shops
and the restaurant and open public space
and they started work and if you see
what that looks like
that is something that could be done at
easter water
here here rose area thank you councillor
locke
right nobody else got lined up at the
moment to speak so
for me this i don't believe it does have
a detrimental impact at all on either
the royal hotel or the long bridge i
mean
when you look at the photographs we've
got in front of us now
the one in the middle is from where you
see the talk of the otter's statue
just across from the church upon the key
on the west side
it's a very wide expansive river there
in bedford and
you can you all know it well enough
anyway undoubtedly there will be an
impact with these
flats built to pick up on the old theme
of the warehouses that used to be on
the site but if you look the southern
part which is a bit with the
you can see the royal hill hotel clearly
enough still
you've got brunswick wars building there
which is proposed to
have as a restaurant then you've got the
public realm square
and the cafe there and not behind there
you've got your before
it doesn't impact on that hilltop scene
behind at all when you look at that
middle photograph and the other one the
bottom one which is taken from across
outside the police station to shut down
police station
um again you get a good view of the
royal hotel there
and the bronzer water refurbished
brunswick wharf building that's
something i know councillors over the
years
have always wanted to maintain is the
brunswick wharf building
and i've often walked across the bridge
and thought that'd make a splendid fish
restaurant there
and if we could only go down through the
gardens there the memorial gardens
onto that frontage with a walkway all
along the front now
how brilliant it would be that side of
the river is in sun all day long
in the summer all day long whereas the
west side's in shade
from our lunchtime moments so
the only thing for me that i would like
to see is some planting if you look
again
at that middle picture you've got quite
a high flood warning
i think i saw another one with it's very
high that because i saw one with a
somebody in front of it and it's taller
than average height person
and you'll see the steps go up to the
private and their private gardens for
the flats
they're not public gardens in there but
i would like to see on that seven meter
wide
um promenade trees which must
match what's a long bit of a key on the
west side now heard what sean said about
the ea
environment agency wanting a clear
uninterrupted
walkway along there well seven meters
hello with that is actually
and i'm sure if we put uh tree planting
um halls which they're gonna do in
barnstable street
uh tree pets they call them and there's
specific holes
dug out so roots don't spread out and
start undermining drainage and
buildings etc i'm sure we could do that
along there the other thing i would like
to see
i've not heard it mentioned i don't know
if sean knows or not
but i would like to see some form of
public conveniences
somewhere in this public realm area
whether it's at the back of that
brunswick wharf building which is
proposed to be a restaurant
i've had i've had it put to me that
changes changing places
should be incorporated somewhere in this
if we've got the undercar
underground car park under that public
square
for 45 vehicles and three of those are
disabled parking spaces
surely somewhere on this they could
provide public conveniences don't have
to be
a big lot but certainly this changing
places for people with disabilities i
think
on something of this scale ought to be
provided
and uh this is really i i suppose
something that the
the developer planning permission is
granted on this
oh look i hope along with providing some
trees along that front
it's pretty bleak blank look at the
moment along there you can see there
which isn't to scale but there are
people walking along walking along
and that wall's quite a wall that flood
defense wall
um the five the five
grade two cottages or houses in
barnstable street well
i i did hear in the presentation that
plaster working
plaster works in one of them considered
to be quite
interesting to be frank in my view from
outside they don't really
look that special to me but
but they are moving the new the proposed
development will me move back
with a wider pavement on the other side
of baseball street
which again must improve the prospect
for those
those uh grade two listed buildings
um the royal hotel does have a covenant
that gives them the right of a view
straight through that public realm
square there and that will be maintained
and i do
i just don't believe that um the
heritage aspects
are that severely impacted on
by the development undoubtedly there is
an impact but i don't believe
it's detrimental in my view the the
benefits from this scheme outweigh the
perceived
slight to me slight impacts on the
conservation
i mean the conservation area it's pretty
poor in it when you look at it
currently it's dreadful at the moment
and
if we go through the wooded surgery and
christie elson we all got that letter
round where
she mentioned the overshadowing well
unfortunately there will be some
overshadowing
but i also read that if there was a
lower building on that north end
in the winter the winter solstice you
would still have overshadowing
of that roof there to an extent so it's
not
necessarily the height there it's just
that the sun is so low
coming in from that angle in the winter
time winter solstice
you're bound to get some overshadowing
there the privacy aspect the overlooking
well
you heard the planning manager mention
that the upstairs rooms are offices in
the main and training rooms
there are consulting rooms downstairs
which in the main
are screened um so whilst i do accept
there's an element
of overlooking i don't think it's that
detrimental
that it would warrant refusing this
application in my view
um the concerns again from wood are
about the electromagnetic fields
generated from the substation in that
well that's that's been
addressed and considered and
western power at retin they're more
concerned with people sleeping within
five meters
of a substation they'd have concerns if
people were sleeping
within five meters of substation so
that's been addressed as well
we had the dated on the 25th of march
again
one of those late presentations that
sean and we've all had to look at
the overwintering mate and migrant
migratory bird survey
for brunswick wharf and the conclusions
are
it's considered that the february and
march over wintering
and migratory bird service support the
conclusions
drawn that mud flats
on to brunswick wharf are of little
value to wading birds
particularly the rarer wading birds
associated with the ssi
um so that's one of the late
representations we had from richard
green ecology
now for me and i know the area well
enough upstream
of the old long bridge that is a very
important ssi for me
all the way up through up to the old
iron bridge this side of the
of the old bridge i don't think is as
important as further upstream we've got
the mud flats
and the reed beds etc the other one that
we had in was
from delver pacman redler on the which
was an
independent review of the brunswick
wharf sun path study
and that was dated again late on 24th of
march
but that again mentions as i did a
minute ago there will be some
impact in in the wintertime to a degree
on the solar arrays but whatever is lost
there in electrical generation
um in the winter months for the
overshadowing
let's remember that on top of this
development there are solar panels
which will increase uh solar-powered
solar generated electricity on this
whole site in general
i know it's going to affect with a
surgery slightly
but again i'm prepared to accept that
that
is something that um i don't think
the detriment warrants refusing this
application because of that
thank you um
right well we've got two more councillor
heard would like to come back
and then councillor craig thank you
chair a couple of points
i forgot to mention i think um the view
coming in
to biddeford from the instill direction
uh the impressions we've seen are far
more acceptable to me anyway
than what's there at present as a
tourist you may well take
the more scenic route and come in that
way and you think what am i coming into
with all this
affliction the right hand side with the
proposal it's far far
better and gives a far far a better
impression of the town
the second point was mr friend mentioned
the height of the building a couple of
meters above what we're talking about
today
and that was something obviously
happened haven't verified because i
haven't uh
had the information before but it's
interesting to think that it was a
higher building there than that's
proposed
now and i do think the um the shading
impact on wood is minimal looking at the
reports and i agree news panels on top
of the proposed buildings will take care
of any
uh loss of solar generation from that
point of view
um and i think that's that's that's it
really i i do think we should go ahead
with this or this
proposal should go ahead i don't think
there's a better proposal on the table
and as i said before
if we don't go ahead with this one i
think we'll be sitting here in year or
someone will be sitting here in years to
come
saying well why didn't we do it and
there's nothing further coming forward
thank you chair thanks councilman
councillor brown
our vice chairman of commission yes um
thank you chairman
um as the other committee members have
done i expect we
spent many many hours on looking at this
excellent
report um i think many of the concerns
have actually
um been been addressed this is terrible
derelict site
i have to say that i come from
torrington where we have another awful
derelict site
and we would probably jump at the chance
of this regeneration
of the site i do believe that paragraph
196 to the mppf which talks about
weighing harm against public benefits
and i do think the public benefits from
this
this application does you know far away
any any hiring chairman so
i will be voting for the application
thank you
thanks councillor brown councillor locke
thank you chair um i'd just like to okay
what uh
one of the points that you made um
counselor leather
the trees along the front i would really
like to see
trees along the front because it would
it would break my main concern
is the view from west of the water
and i think it just looks like a blank
wall
all the way along and put on top of that
a five-storey
block of flats it's an enormous um
impact on the view from from the key the
other side
and if we could have trees i mean you're
probably aware that the town council
really values our christmas lights
and we have a lovely display and we've
had many many compliments about it and
as a counsellor for east the water i
would like to see the lights continue
down the other side on the trees on the
other side and i think it would look
beautiful with the reflections in the
water
and it seems to me that it's quite a
wide walkway that'd still be
vehicle you know room for regular access
with tree planting down there and i
really would like
um the developers to go back to whoever
it is
objecting i think it's the environment
agency about whoever it is
and see if we can get some form of
greenery along the front
of of the um development on the walkway
and my overall conclusion is i mean i'm
sitting here and i'm
i still don't know what to do it's
i'm i really like a lot of the
development
but i don't like the six story flats i
don't think they're appropriate for
biddeford
i don't think they fit in with the
historic character of
everything but then i have to weigh
against that the viability and if
we turn this down um
we'll be losing quite a lot of good
things as well
and i'm concerned because i represent
easter water
the people of easter water want this
development
and so i have to support them as well
and
so it's for me personally it's been a
really
really difficult decision and i think i
have to go with the viability argument
that if we turn this down
we may not get anything else in fact we
may
even get something worse so
um i think i'm going to vote for it
thank you thanks councillor craig will
you may i'm glad you
support the view about trees because i
have always had it in
in my mind that whenever this site was
developed whenever
we get this lovely promenade along the
river there
with seating some benches along and
trees to give shade in the summer
because as i said it's in the sun all
day long and that would really enhance
the view looking across from
the west side of the river there
councillor locke it doesn't cover the
small points i
forgot to mention earlier on i mean i
spent a long time
um reading the environment agencies and
the ecology report which i found most
interesting with regard to the mud flats
and
what the repairs to the sea urchin the
key wall was going to be and
how they were going to drill holes into
the wall to make plants being able to
grow
which i found very very interesting and
then i've never seen before on page 27
the designing out crime officers report
he finishes off um i must admit i was
surprised to see the overall proposal
receives the negative press and that's
from the crime
officers report so i found that was an
interesting comment
thanks and of course i think um
one thing that's nobody's thought of
when we when we're
doing this planning balance and weighing
up the pros and cons
is the flood alleviation scheme of this
which is very important in my view for
easter water
this will you know it will really
improve
the lot of all bastable street with this
flood prevention scheme that's
incorporated into this development and
the ea
in the future extending that as well so
this is a very important aspect of it as
well
which is also the public benefit council
mcgoth
thank you very much mr chairman we
definitely think you're liking some
things i assure you that because the
flood prevention scheme is
paramount to the barcelona street uh mr
chevrolet
mr howard just put a post that posted up
so he didn't just put a um
a plan up here then of the guard in
there we had a
cluster of trees we're in a public space
could you just
go back to there that's it right there
would we not be able to ask the
developer to bring those
trees forward
well we can we can ask i mean our
planning planning office when they
discuss the planting scheme with the
developer if it's approved
can raise these issues that the
committee have raised about trees
and the planting of them because as i
mentioned the two gardens shown there
are private gardens there for the
residents of the flats so it's a bit
bleak looking across as councillor craig
you mentions
from the west looking across to east the
water and you've just got that great
long wall
which is the flood defense wall with the
car park underground behind
sean you want to come in there
uh yeah thank you chair if i can just
comment on the tree planting element
seems to be a point of discussion um i
did cover this with the
applicant who has confirmed um that the
ea
do require free and unfettered access of
seven meters
along the key walkway um which is why
it's shown as uh there's no furniture
there or
what have you tree planting um i would
comment that that's
from my understanding was a civil matter
that walkway is to be retained by
tourist council
in the future um so they may maybe
within the control
of those council in the future to do
something there
but the landscaping scheme is fairly um
extensive for development of this type
in this location on a brownfield site
and i think members need to consider
on the basis of landscape scheme that's
in front of them um as opposed to
seeking any
additional planting on that key wall
which i don't think we'll be able to do
as part of this application at this time
thanks for that sean you've just
confirmed then that
what i can when i was led to believe
that this walkway this promenade
will be a public right-of-way once it's
constructed and handed over to torridge
yeah yeah right well
chairman chairman it's it's damien
it's damian solista i i just wanted as
well you you touched upon the fact that
you mentioned about uh
wc's and whether there were any public
conveniences as part of the application
and and again i noted that sean has just
said then
uh you have to consider the planting
scheme before you
and again unless there are any uh public
conveniences already mentioned on this
then
again my view would be you have to
consider what's before you today
i just wondered whether there were any
uh public conveniences as part of the
application
whether sean could comment on that
please
yeah can i respond to you yes financial
uh yeah there's no public conveniences
as part of this application
um clearly within the restaurant on the
floor plans it is shown there are
toilets as you'd expect in a restaurant
but no actually did
his public conveniences
right thank you thank you that's
something that
may have to be looked at yes yeah we've
just got we've just got to consider
what's before us today we can't ask for
i think for me on going back to the
heritage aspect and the conservation
area aspect
council brown is dead right when she and
sean alluded to it 196 in the mppf which
talks about where a development proposal
will lead to less than substantial harm
and i really believe
that to be the case on this nobody else
wants to speak it's been moved
to grant it's been by councillor mcgough
and it was seconded by councillor locke
so i know we've given it a very very
good
discussion i'm now proposed to go to the
vote so sandra would you take the vote
please
yes chair thank you councillor brown
or princely christie against
councillor craigie or
councillor leather for councillor lock
or councillor mcgoff
four penciller watson or
penciller wiseman or pencil harley
four chair that's eight four
and one against all right thanks very
much for that
sandra thank you everybody who's
contributed to that discussion on that
and the debate
and all the various views that we've
taken this morning on that
um right i'm going to call
the meeting this part of our meeting
today to a close now
we'll take the rest of the agenda
tomorrow when we meet at 9
30 again to go through the rest of our
applications right
and again we've got quite a big one in
with tomorrow's that's the one down at
tadworthy road so that's quite a big one
that's going to take quite a bit of
discussion probably
but thanks everybody you've contributed
will continue with our agenda tomorrow
okay until then
i'll say good morning to everybody thank
you to the public who've joined
on youtube this morning for watching i
hope you have um
well enjoyed the meeting and and learned
all about this scheme
and all the pros and cons of it which
we've had to do
um and thanks to all the contributors
i'll say i'll close the meeting